it's a 45 billion dollar deal that would  combine two of the largest cable  companies in the United States cod cash  is bidding to buy Time Warner Cable and  it's more than 11 million customers  adding to comcast space of nearly 22  million video subscribers the vaio would  reshape the country's media landscape in  both pay TV and broadband comcast with  sellers spin-off nearly five million  subscribers as part of the deal but the  combined Comcast Time Warner would still  be the biggest cable operator with about  30 million customers reaching nearly one  in three American homes that pay for  television already dominate on the west  coast the merger would also put Comcast  on the map in New York Ohio and Texas  the deals about internet service to  comcast has more than 20 million  broadband subscribers time warner cable  would add another 11 million to that  putting a new bigger comcast in control  of nearly a third of the american  broadband market